welcome to hannity tonight another big
win at the u.s supreme court this time
surrounding your freedom of religion now
full detail straight ahead we'll
interview the coach that was at the
heart of this big ruling today also
nancy pelosi likes to say that she will
take a punch or throw a punch for kids
last week the speaker caught on tape
actually throwing an elbow at
congresswoman myra flores young daughter
congresswoman flores will respond also
tonight we begin with the left's weekend
of rage and despair and lying and
fundraising emails even roe v wade is no
more democrats have descended into a
state of full-blown lying hysteria yet
again now keep in mind this decision did
not outlaw abortion in america instead
they decided who will decide they return
the issue to the states to decide you're
elected officials so ultimately the
american people will decide allowing
voters to debate decide the rules and
regulations surrounding abortion in
their respective states but democrats
they're not interested in honest debate
so over the weekend they took to the
streets now some proudly display very
graphic vulgar signs like this one here
calling justice amy coney barrett
well i can't even say it another sign
telling the justices to burn in hell
others evoking coat hangers displayed
cartoon genitalia
and stated that god was pro-killing
babies one common theme at all the
demonstrations in america that we are
doomed and the supreme court needs to go
in other words they are calling for an
insurrection against a co-equal branch
of government now the new york times
even detailed what they call a
step-by-step plan to discipline the u.s
supreme court by impeaching justices and
packing the court and according to top
democrats well one way or the other the
u.s supreme court must be punished take
a look
this court has lost legitimacy they have
burned whatever legitimacy they may
still have had after their gun decision
after their voting decision after their
union decision they just took the last
of it and set a torch to it with the roe
versus wade opinion and thanks to how
this court was put together its
credibility has never been more in
question
and this decision came at a time when
the country is already dangerously
divided there must be consequences for
such a deeply destabilizing action and
hostile takeover of our democratic
institutions to allow that to stand is
to allow it to happen
now the hysteria was even worse in
chicago where failed mayor lori
lightweight lightfoot had this to say
about supreme court justice clarence
thomas take a look at this
now we know what happened with the
supreme court yesterday and if you read
clarence commons concurrence he said
thank you
clarence thomas
[Applause]
[Music]
now remember the mayor is one of many
democrats who promoted violence against
the court in may she issued a call to
arms and claim that the court was coming
for gay people even worse two years
earlier democratic leader that's right
chuckie schumer he threatened justices
right on the steps of the u.s supreme
court saying you have released the
whirlwind gorsuch and kavanaugh and you
will pay the price you won't know what
hit you
uh what did that mean chuck because now
violent left-wing groups are now showing
up at their private homes meaning the
justices one man had a plot to
assassinate justice cavanaugh meanwhile
other left-wing groups are committing
huge acts of violence all over the
country all in the name of abortion
rights over the weekend in lynchburg
virginia vandals targeted a pro-life
pregnancy center spray
spray painting quote if abortion ain't
safe you ain't safe another pregnancy
center in colorado is lit on fire and
spray-painted with a similar message in
portland oregon private businesses all
over town were damaged during a violent
pro-abortion riot numerous windows were
smashed there was also more spray
painting more graffiti one message
reading quote kill the supreme court
meanwhile out in l.a one rioter was
arrested for attacking a police officer
with a makeshift flame thrower and
arizona pro-abortion protesters there
attempting to storm the the state senate
building and trapping lawmakers inside
according to one state senator quote we
are currently there being held hostage
inside the senate building due to
members of the public trying to breach
our security and we smell tear gas and
the children of one of the members are
in the office sobbing with fear
unfortunately fake news cnn msdnc they
love insurrection talk but apparently
not now they love
covering it only if it advances what
their political agenda democrats the
media mob only seem to care about
democracy when it's politically
expedient safety security they only
speak out against violence when it
advances their political cause and of
course they never let a crisis go to
waste in the hours following the road
decision top democrats they were trying
to raise money what a shock the dnc
asking people to donate 25 bucks to
protect abortion rights nancy pelosi
asking for 15 bucks beto bozo o'rourke
he was only begging for three dollars a
person and then there's president joe
biden instead of leading the fight to
quote restore abortion rights he's off
to saudi arabia why he's going to that
what he called pariah nation uh to kiss
the ass of the crown prince that he
claims is responsible for killing
journalist jamal khashoggi but he's
there to beg for oil because he's
letting domestic production lay by the
wayside we have enough resources to
supply this country with oil and gas for
hundreds of years now this week he made
a pit stop in europe and frankly he
didn't look too well during a photo op
he looked dazed and confused at times
staring off into space unable to hold
down
simple basic conversation or be present
during meetings with these world leaders
needless to say between biden's
cognitive struggles the horrific state
of our economy the general woke
lawlessness on the left voters are
leaving the democratic party in droves
look at this in the past 12 months alone
more than 1 million voters have now
switched their party affiliation to the
gop hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else